[Music]
we're gonna pull out elements people
tend not to be able to even learn from
the traditional vessels anymore your
Hollywood fantasies and your modern
ending sensibility start to take over
and you have a one-to-one kind of thing
between attack and technique so you're
not looking for the subtle things and
then you also have a what-if mentality
which is different from the traditional
mentality which is as if okay so this
has been called micro drilling or
drilling you can take parts out
but the assumption is that there it's in
the technique and you should be able to
do it so right right here the first
mistake I see is that people are not
neutralizing this grid part and you're
pushing on that like this okay we'll
ignore that one for now but this prick
goes like that do you see my fingers hi
go keep her full grip run okay okay now
as I changed my hand positioning I want
you to keep your full grip again
do you see we go here watch watch his
body his elbow and his shoulder you see
you see how I'm doing that so when I go
here you're basically your energy is
pushing on him and it goes in this leg
when you pour it over it goes outside
you see I think he ends up there not
from me
cutting a partner not for me going oh
that's not going to change it you're
gonna get this kind of crunch how you're
all getting bigger people of course will
not go down
but I come around here and boom you
throw that elbow forward that way okay
and then his elbows lower than what are
you guys down okay let's - hi
so this manipulation of the elbow so
here I am on the inside
all right on this side I'm on the back
inside so I don't want his arm to go
straight I want it
I keep manipulating so on the front side
that elbows come past me these yeah I
I'm being grabbed here but I'm
controlling the elbow it very much like
this
from the grip and then the same thing
goes when I'm here like this
it's elbow has fall forward this is how
we've done these different techniques
[Music]
where there's a lot of manipulation
from the grip of the joint actively it's
one way of getting off the joint to the
trunk because you're breaking down his
ability to keep me outside see there you
disconnect
the truck he's also teaching your
parries your pari right hold these are
all your Perry's is for a low kick so to
speak and a deeper level it's all energy
utilization this is being contested so I
ain't go up the harm this is being
contested right here don't I go so bold
throw the elbow it's not enough to go I
don't know how you guys are doing it but
you have that but you don't have the
elbow oh I have to feel his elbow you
see see how I'm turning that from the
grip boom so I feel for it
[Music]
and you're looking for that elbow and
you see this song is not only lower but
there's a hole there where the other arm
right has this straight arm like that
that was not working for the technique
and that was brought about by
neutralizing the grip and going up the
elbow and you keep that action going you
see that then you'll have it here's
where you can reconcile that energy
elbow and move to keep this elbow
neutral so you're not pushing they're
pulling which means you don't step
wherever the grip is telling you so once
you put hands on it once I put hands on
it right I have two points of contact
that tell me where it's zero not plus
one push plus one pull so that's going
to tell me where I step to do this right
it's going to tell me exactly what I
need to go so I can't just have a
choreography in my head that goes I
always just step like that you see your
plus one pull so you have to wait for it
neutralize that grip then you don't tell
you where to go
[Music]
he said not everything's going to get
the opposite problem alright there's
stuff going on on the inside so when I
have is elbow like this I have to use
certain let's just let's go the inside
of the musculature level so I don't go
like this with my shoulders my shoulder
blade my shoulder blade goes up and down
now I'm up not my hand so when it's time
to cut I don't go like this
I don't pull here which is what you will
naturally do when you try to not
reconcile this strip and you cut here so
when I go over the top like this and
then I lower I drop that shoulder blade
do you guys think I'm doing that so it
drops I'm going to stop I'm going to
start lowering it lowering at lowering
and lowering Lorre and now it's at the
bottom two cuts not done do you see that
all right so once that's locked in place
then everything else walks in place
right and I have that cookie swell and
that's what finishes the cut you see you
see how I'm doing that you guys are
doing this
you over here and you're going like that
there's an opposite shoulder blade went
up right and then you just have your arm
to go
so instead right when I hit here
shoulder blade sets bold and then once
it's done setting it my arm doesn't move
anymore
I'm using my whole body you see and I
get that and it doesn't take any energy
because I reconciled the grip I'm not
cutting into script so hold there it's
locked
and then by lowering so get a good grip
strong strong strong strong strong
strong right over the top lock the
shoulder blade and go I tell you just
you want to organize your body for a
mechanical advantage right over your
other self so my no no not going to be
not going to work over the top set the
shoulder blade move okay try it right
and now stay there he in this little
narrative he wants to fight me right so
what's he going to do
yes do you see what he's doing okay so I
don't have to go like this he's gonna do
that this was going like Rick he's gonna
do that go and you see see how a
movement that's going to be our next
little Michael he's gonna move and I
keep that relationship hey then now a
new drill so set yourself back up
is he moose go you keep this
relationship there's parts of me I don't
even care where they're located as a
practitioner okay stay there wait till I
get up okay he goes he's moving go move
go you see go back
go back watch the difference I'm late
though I have to be able to read read
him back I'm early blend here we go
do you see again to go back oh do you
see again I and I stay with okay so
that's all every place you don't do that
ended in kyon right so if I move early
before you moved then I'm gonna have to
pull this thing you got it if I move
late he moves right then I'm gonna get
jammed and this is why you guys do this
one without the ten o'clock but you're
still pushing on this arm so if my
timings off if I'm early
I'll be press in terms of neutralizing
the left arm if I'm late I'll be pressed
in terms of neutralizing the right arm
and I'm gonna have these muscles on one
of them so instead it's just timing see
that this happened get on the arm but
then he's just gonna fall it's all it is
much easier when you can feel it
I think some of you are like wait he's
movie yeah you want him to move just
staying with him okay this steps are
with him okay
a lot of you are just going well I in
turn and then you step wherever no it's
the same thing do you see how he keeps
turning at me
so my second step is what does it
relation with is in relation with him
boom can't be your own things can't be
how to have it on the first step I
always go here then it's with him but
your second step can't be its own thing
you in this relationship and it's all
about what you feel in your arms one
since I don't feel plus one push plus
one floor like that neutral the neutral
harmonization one - okay let's go a
little side
it has to be a misunderstanding so he
goes and I go 163 or okay so he has to
get up that makes the technique because
an arrogance has some sense that's why I
continue on okay but go back what do you
work and as he starts to come towards me
go ahead and I move this like this look
what happens he's following this way you
understand that it's not that you keep
chasing me around you do you understand
so where where I go in the
neutralization of this you're creating
this do you see that right so if you're
rude kiss not coming around because
you're giving them a base they're not
falling so come back and I'm going like
this okay do you see what I'm doing no
do you have to go yeah you don't have to
go but if I fight don't have plus one
push then he will fall into that space
yes you have to be aware a lot of times
you starting to pick this hand up
because you go to the last position that
you're actually grabbed right I'm giving
him this base just just by me holding it
up and when I let it go let's do it like
the ticking okay
oh okay there he goes I'm holding you up
as I think I'm not okay don't let go of
your grip got it so I'm moving it around
and I'm holding you up and giving your
base now watch as I let this I let this
go dead you see that and so that's what
brings them around and that's what I try
my second step - okay so watch that you
went +1 push on that hand cuz your get
your stabilizing